[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكم
اتشرف بوجودكم هنا اليوم
شاهدنا اسوا استهداف
رئيس فاسده
قام باعتقالي خصمه زائفه
في خضم انتخابات رئاسيه
يخسر فيها بشكل فظيع
[تصفيق]
اذا هذا يسمى تدخل في الانتخابات وهذه
محاوله جديده لسرقه الانتخابات الرئيسيه
والامر الاهم ان هذا اضطهاد سياسي
يخرج لا نشهده الا في دول الفاشيه وهذا
سيكون يوما مخزيا
وبعد الانسان يذكره التاريخ بالكاميرا
اسوا رئيسا فاسد والاهم
الرئيس الذي مع عصبه من السفاحين
والبلطجيه حاولوا ان يدمروا الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه
ولكنهم سيخفقون ونحن سنفوز بشكل اكبر
وافضل
[تصفيق]
اتهامه رئيس سابق للولايات المتحده
للولايات المتحده
تحت قانون التجسس لعام 1917
اذا جرم
لا
عقوبه له الا الاعدام
وحكم بعشره سنوات علي بسجل انني حست
واحتفظت بوثائق وهذه من اسوا النظريات
القانونيه التي تشهدها المحاكم قانون
التجسس استخدم لمعاقبه الخونه والجواسيس
ولا علاقه له برئيس سابق يحتفظ به وثائقي
وبشكل قانونيه هذا القانون لا ينطبق في
حالته لا ينطبق عليها قانون التجوس التجسس
ولكن قانون
السجلات الرئاسيه والذي لم يؤتى على ذكره
في لائحه الاتهام التي تضم 49 صفحه هذه
القضيه قضيه مدنيه وليست جنائيه انا لكل
الحقل لامتلاكي وحيازه تلك الوثائق وهذا
هذه
وردت وربما هذه القضيه
لها علاقه
بقضيه كلينتن هو احتفظ باحتفاضه
بتسعه وسبعين
مقطعا مسجلا
ومناقشات تتعلق بسياسات الولايات المتحده
الخارجيه الدفاعيه والجنوبيه
لمحادثاتي الرئيس السابق كلينتن مع كل
رؤساء وزعماء دول العالم حقائق حساسه بشان
مفاوضات التجاره من احاطات الرئيس مناقشات
مع وزير الخارجيه بشان النزاع في بوسنا
وغيرها اذا كل تلك امور مهمه
لما يعاقب
جنائيا بسبب تلك التسجيلات ولكن عندما رفع
قضيه فازها
القاضي جاكسون وتحت قانون
اذن القرار بالفصل بين المواد
الشخصيه والمواد الرئاسيه
يحتفظ بها رئيس خلال فترته
[موسيقى]
بقرار من الرئيس
اداره عاديه حتى اداره معارضه كانت ستعتبر
ذلك نهاء نهايه ولكن ليس اداره بايدن
الفاسده
قرار
اذا هو ينصه على ان اداره سجلات والارشيف
الوطنيه لا تملكها صلاحيه والسلطه لفصل
المواد بموجب قانون سجلات الرئاسيه
تلك الاداره لم تستحوذ على تلك السجلات
حينها الرئيس يتمتع بسلطات غير محدوده
لاتخاذ قرارات بشانه التخلص من وثائق اذن
سلطات غير مقيده ولا
الاداره ولا الكونجرس يملكون حق الطعن
الفيتو اذا قانون السجلات الرئاسيه لا
يلزم
بسلطات
بموجبه تتعلق به
السريه الوثائق وبموجب ذلك القانون هذه
المسؤوليه متروكه حصرا لرئيس الولايات
المتحده اذا ذلك هو القرار
[تصفيق]
فكروا في الامر
بمعنى اخر اي وثائق يقرروا رئيس اخذها معه
له كامل الحق في ذلك فهذا حق مطلق وهذا هو
القانون
وهذا امر
يراه الناس
وعليهم ان يسقطوا تلك القضيه مباشره لانها
تدمر
النظام في امريكا ولهذا
لا رئيس اخر حتى هؤلاء الذين احتفظوا
بوثائق اكثر مني لم يسبق ان حقق في امرهم
ولم تسند لهم تهم جنائيه لان هذه
الادانه السوريه والتي نشرت
وسال الناس لماذا احتفظت بكل تلك
الصناديقه
والجوابه هو انني املك كل الحقوق بموجب
بقانون سجلات الرئاسيه والتي هذه صناديق
تتضمنوا ممتلكات خاصه
بقمصان واحذيه وغيرها وكما رايتم في الصور
لو كان شخص اخر
اسقط بعض هذه صدى المرتبه على الارض
الاخبار عناوين الصحف والالاف والالاف من
صور البيت الابيض اللي كانت قد نشرت بعض
مصورين البيت الابيض الموجودون يلتقطون
صورا كثيره ونحن احتفظنا به كثير من هذه
الصور في تلك الصناديق اذا تذكارات ملابس
وغيرها وغيرها لما اتمكن من التمحيص كل
تلك الصناديق فهذا عمل مجهده وكنت مستعدا
لذلك ولكن حياتي منشغله بالكامل
وجعلوها اكثر انشغالا لانني اكافحه واناضل
وتحت وبموجب قرار
يبدو يبدو انه لم يكن هنالك اي الحاح او
السرعه لان القرار كان بمثابه القانون
وربما تتذكرون بعض الصور
عندما التقطت صور
وعندما قاموا
مداهمه
وقاموا بوضع
الوثائق على
الارض تلك الصوره المخزيه ربما تتذكرونها
والامر لم يكن كذلك عندما اداها
المنتجع اذا نشرت تلك الصور
قاموا بمصادرتي سجلات الطبيه وشهاده
الشهادات الميلادي وغيرها واعتذر عن ذلك
وحتى اتوا بشخص ليكسر الخزنه وهذه للمره
الاولى وقاموا بكسر خزنتي ولم يجدوا فيها
شيئا البته لم يكن فيها شيء على الاطلاق
وبموجي بقانون السجلات الرئاسيه وهو قانون
مهم
يحق لي التفاوض مع اداره السجلات والارشيف
الوطني بموجب بشان ما يمكن ان اخذه قبل ان
يداهمني عناصر الاف بي اي وكان هنالك ايضا
مقاطع مصوره للامنيه
وطبعا نحن نعرف ان التعديل الرابع من
الدستور والذي يمنع
بحثه غير مشروع والمصادره
وسباستيان اغطى هذا الموضوع تماما وانا
لست
من يعتقد انني فوق القانون انا من اطبق
القانون والتزم بالقانون
واداره وزاره العدل الفاسده يعتقدون انهم
فوق القانون لم يسبق ان كان هنالك معياران
للعيد للعداله
صارخان
باردا احتفظ بكميه هائله من الوثائق عندما
الرئيس وحتى عندما كان عضوا في مجلس
الشيوخ وكان ذلك امر غير قانوني
وطبعا هو اخذ تلك الوثائق عندما كان
سناتورا
صدمه عندما تبين ذلك بايدن ارسل
1875 صندوقا لجامعه دلوير ما جعل عمليه
البحث والتمحين الصعبه وصعبه للغايه ورفض
التخلي عنها ورفض ان يسمح للاخرين
بالاطلاع عليها
معظم الوثائق السريه التابعه لبادل
ذهبت الى
واشنطن دي سي وعائلته حصلت على اموال
طائله من الصين اتساءل
اذا كان اصدقائنا من الصين اطلعوا على تلك
الوثائق بعضها كان مخزنا بشكل غير بشكل
غير امن في ما يسمى بمركزي بايدن وموال
طائله اتت من الصين
وطبعا كانت الوثائق طبعا
منتشره
وملقات في كراجه الذي سياره الفيراري
المشهوره ومعظم الاوقات كانت كان باب
الكراج
مفتوحا كانت
على عكس الذي
يملك سلطه وصلاحيه رفع السريه عن الوثائق
فبعد عندما كان نائب الرئيس لم يكن يملكه
السلطه والصلاحيه لرفع السري عن اي وثائق
وبدل من ان
اجراءات بايدا بدلا من ان تكون
يتم التعامل معها بموجب بقانون السجلات
الرئاسيه
تم تعامل معها
بقانون ولكن لم يحدث له شيء ولم يتم تفتيش
[موسيقى]
ونتذكر كلينتين والتي وضعت خادما او سيرفر
خاصه في
منزلها وطبعا كانت تحتفظ
بالايميلات وغيرها من
المواد الخاصه بمؤسسه مؤسسه
وكانت تحتفظ بايميلات في ذلك
الخادم غير قانوني وبعضها تم تسريبه
للكمبيوتر انتني وينر وطبعا هناك الكثير
من غيره من الامراء القانونيه فيها في
حاسوبه المحمول وطبعا الشكر لله بانها لم
تصل الى كرسي الرئاسه
[تصفيق]
لم تملك الصلاحيه لرفع السريع عن تلك
الايميلات وكذلك جو
هل تسمحون لليبي ان اشرب الماء
[موسيقى]
هي ابرد مما كنت اعتقد ولكن الجو حار هنا
طبعا شكرا لكم شكرا على تهنئه بعيد
الميلاد
[تصفيق]
كان عيد ميلاد لطيف
عيد ميلاد لطيف اذا رائع
عيد ميلاد سعيد
[موسيقى]
ولكن سنجعله من عيد من عيد الميلادي هذا
الاروع والك
[تصفيق]
وره عندما قامت عندما قامت كلينتون في
مسحه الايميلات وكان ذلك 33 الف رساله
الكترونيه
قامت بمسحها
ضد طلب الاستدعاء اذا قررت
قررت مسحه تلك الايميلات وقامت بتكسير
هواتفها النقاله
وتقولون انني انا عرقلت صير العداله ما
فعلته كان
عرقله للعداله في اسوا صورها وافضل صورها
ولم يفعل اي شيء لها
وزاره العدل الحموها ولم يصبروا اي مذكرات
استدعاء ولم يشكل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشرطه بالمقص
ولكنه لما يتهم او يدان او يسجان هنالك
عدد كبير من الامثله
وامر لا يصدق ولا كان صديقا لي قبل هو شخص
طيب وكان ينبغي ان يستخدم كان ينبغي ان
يكون مستشارا في انتخابات 2016 كان يقول
لزوجته
كالوري اذهب الى وسكان اذهب الى
وحتى عندما سقط ما يسمى بالرمز النووي رمز
وجهها
فقد 22 مليون ايميل
واداره الارشيف الوطني لم تستمكن من
احصائي كل السجلات
وطبعا شوهد شوهد شوهدت شاحنه فيها اجهزه
تقطيع وتمزيق الورقه وجدت او شهدت في
محيطي ديكشيني وايضا هناك من اخذ
[موسيقى]
الاثاث
والاواني الخزفيه لو فعلها ترامب ذلك لوجه
مشاكل
اذا تسليح ووزاره العدل الرضي امر لا يمكن
تصديقه ما حدث امر لا يمكن يصديقه وهو مضر
ببلدنا الديمقراطيون جميعا وبشكل غير
قانوني
خرقوا علاقه علاقه المحامي
بموكله ما فعله بمحاميه جميعهم فعلوا
امورا فظيعه ومشينه لا تصدق عمليه التسريب
لا تصدق وهي غير قانونيه على الاطلاق
وعرفنا الكثير من صحيفه او صحف
واشنطن بوست وان
الخدعه
اذا ما اردتم ان تقرا وتعرفوا عنها فقط
اقراوا واشنطن بوست والتي وضعها في انحدار
ولكنها ربما بعد وضعها افضل
بسبب الاحداث ولكن كان ينبغي الا تكون
الامور على هذا النحو اذا اردت لا نريد ان
نعرف الاخبار من تسريب في صحف مثل نيويورك
تانجو واشنطن
اذا هي اشبه بحنفيه او اسطنبور تسريب
ولكننا لم نعرف اي شيء عن
مخططات الرش
لبايدن وهنالك محقق خاصه يحقق في تلك
الخروقات والمحقق الخاص هو مجنون اخرق وفي
كثير من الاحيان حتى
المحقق الخاص
لم يعثر على شيء وهو برا مايك بنسى وانا
سعيد بذلك
وطبعا وجدت وثائق سريه في منزله ولكنه
بريء
وبعد القصه اخرى تماما وعلينا ان نفكر
فيما قلت طبعا عندما كان اخذ كل تلك
الوثائق والمحقق الخاص في قضيتي
واسميها قضيتي هو بلطجي وانا سميته جاك
سميث المجنون
ولكنه شخص يعمل من وراء الكواليس ولكن
سجله فظيع اذا هو يقوم بعمليات جنسيه
واستهداف سياسي ومعروف
بانه قام باعتقال
الحاكم ولايه فرجينيا ودمر حياته بالكامل
وحياته عائلته عائلة رائعه وانا اعرفهم
ولكن
المحكمه العليا نقضت تلقي القضيه ثمانيه
ضد صفر دمر حائل حاتم ولايه فرجينيا
وعائلته ولكنني انا موجود هنا واحبكم
جميعا احبكم جميعا
[تصفيق]
ولكن ما يقوم به هؤلاء البلطجيه هؤلاء
سفاحين وما فعلوه بحق عائلته هو امر مشين
مقيد واقول لكل ممثلي وسائل الاعلام ال
الزائفه والمزيفه والموجودون هنا
ما فعلوه لعائلتي وذلك الشاب الفتى
وهو استجاب لاكبر مذكرات استدعاء ولم
يجدوا شيئا يدينه الالاف من مذكرات
الاستدعاء من الكونجرس من محقق مستشارين
او محامين زائفين
وتحقيقات ولكن هذه
اريك مميز وما فعله هو وداعا وايفانكا
وبعر به
وهؤلاء اشخاص
مميزون ما فعلوه بحق عائلته واذا هو امر
فظيع ايضا حاول
ان
يدين جون ادوارد بموجب خطه اذا هذا
البلطجي الذي ارسلناه الى المحكمه محكمه
محكمه جمعيه الدوليه في لاهاي هذا الذي لا
يلتزمه بالدستور او حكم القانون هذان
امران يكرههما لو رايتم صورته او لتاملتم
في سوره فهو يبدو كبلطجي وطبعا عندما القى
كلمه يكون واثقا من نفسه هو فقط هو
يعمل يجد نفسه في وزاره غير العدل وزاره
الظلم يصرخ في وجه الاخرين زوجته ايضا
هي المنتجه
[موسيقى]
لبرنامج يتعلق
اذا هذه التحقيقات
وراها وزاره العدل التي شنت عليها حملة
لمده سبع سنوات ضدي وضد الولايات ضد الشعب
الامريكي
كما لو كانوا يريدون زعزعه استقراري بلد
عندما نتذكر
التواضع مع روسيا محاكم البرلمانيه الاولى
والثانيه
وقالوا ان تلك حملات روسيه مضلله ولكن
ما يدفعني
رغم ذلك حصلت على 17 نقطه اضافيه في شعبيه
ووضعنا ووضع افضل كان في الانتخابات افضل
من الانتخابات الاولى لما يسمى بالملفات
المزيفه تذكرون تلك الملف
المزيفه
وتذكرون لم يكن الامر سهلا حينها التجسس
على حمله الانتخابيه امسكنا بهم متلبسين
بالتجسس الاف بي اي
وغيرهم وغيرهم الكثير اذا كل ذلك
ضمن حمله حمله من المعلومات الموضله والتي
تهدف الى حمايه
اليسار
المتطرف ومن غير مصادفه ان تلك التهم خرجت
في نفس اليوم التي كشف في عن ادله بان
حصل على رشوه بقيمه خمس ملايين دولار من
روسيا ولكن وزاره العدل لم تبرز تلك اذا
لم تحظى بتغطيه من القنوات الرئيسيه
الرئيسه الثلاث ولكن محاكمة البرلمانيه
استحوذت على وسائل الاعلام بالكامل ربما
كان هنالك تغطيه لاكثر من 350 دقيقه
[تصفيق]
ولم اشهد حبا فالذي شاهدته في شوارع ميامي
حب جمع لم اشهد حبا بذلك القدر لانهم
يعرفون ما الذي نشهده وما الذي مررنا بهم
يرون ذلك وهم اذكياء ومعظم هؤلاء الاشخاص
اتوا من كوبا وفنزويلا وغيرها شهدوا
الظلمه وفي بلدانهم واقول ان الولايات
المتحده امام مضت في هذا في هذا المسار
فستصبح فنزويلا اخرى
والان نحن نشتري النفط من فنزويلا ونشتري
الاسفلت من فنزويلا ونقوم بتكريره في
هيوستن اسوا نفط نشتريه واشبه بالقاره
ونكرره في هيوسن
نحن لا نستخرج نفطنا النظيف من ارضنا
ونجني من وراه الاموال ونخفضه الضرائب اذا
يريدون
التسليه الامطار عن عمليه التجسس اذا فقط
يريدون ادانتها ادانه
الانظار عن الرشوه بمقدار خمس ملايين خمسه
ملايين دولار اذا هنالك سبعه عشر
شريطا مصورا
الشخص من شركه برسمه وهي اذا
هنالك
لم تتطرق الى ذلك انا تهمته بسبب سؤال لان
عن علاقتنا مع علاقه اوكرانيا
واليسار المتطرف بامكانهم الحصول على
ويحظون بالحمايه الكامله والجمهوريون
عليكم ان تصبحوا اكثر صرامه واكثر ضراوه
عليكم ان تطهروا ذلك عندما يتم اعتقال
الخصم السياسي سنخسر ديمقراطيتنا عندما
تفتح حدودنا وتتزوروا انتخاباتنا فان
بلدنا سيواجه مشاكل
مجمع عندما نفقد استقلاليتنا
[موسيقى]
انحدارا جسيما
واذا ما فلت
الشيوعيون بريشهم فان الامر لن يتوقف عليه
فانهم بل سيواصلون اضطهادهم
للمسيحيين انصار الحياه وغيرهم وغيرهم حتى
المرشحين الجمهوريين المستقبلين علينا ان
ننهي ذلك
فورا والى الابد
من المهم طبعا الان
[موسيقى]
فتحت الامور عن العقالها
الان خرجت
من اغلاق الحدود واخراج كل المجرمين الذين
ياخذون بلادنا بشكل غير قانوني وجعل
امريكا مستقله
من حيث الطاقه وكان بامكاننا انهاء الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه خلال 24 ساعه كنت انا
كنت ساعين محققا خاصا حقيقيا
لاحق اكثر الرؤساء فسادا في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده وهو الرئيس جو بايدن
وعائلته الفاسده ساسمي محققا خاصا
كل الضاليعين في تدمير انتخاباتنا وحدودنا
وبلدنا اذنهم يدمرون بلدنا وعندما يتم
انتخابي مره اخرى وانا سانتخب مره اخرى لن
يكون اما واذا لم انتخب فلن يكون لنا بلد
انا
امحي سامحي انا سامحه
بالدوله العميقه وانا اعرفهم جميعا
هؤلاء الذين يريدون حرمان من حريتي
لانني اناضل من اجلي منعهم من حرمانكم من
حريتهم وهم يريدون الاصمات لانني لن اسمح
لهم باصماتكم او اسكاتكم وانا الوحيد الذي
بامكاني انقاذه هذه الامه لانهم لا
يلاحقونني فقط بل يلاحقونكم وانا اقف في
طريقهم ولكنني لن اتزحزح
في الخامس من
نوفمبر عام 2040
العداله ستتحقق ونستنعيد بلدنا مره اخرى
وسن نجعل امريكا عظيمه مجددا شكرا جزيلا
على حضوركم شكرا جزيلا لكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]